In today's video,
we're going to see what happens
if we take our DIY sandblaster,
and use it on a steak.
We might try it
with salt as well.
[Music]
We recently showed you
how to make a DIY sandblaster,
and today, we're going
to see what happens
if we sandblast this piece
of steak here.
So here's the basic idea.
We are going to sandblast
our steak first,
raw, then cooked,
and then if it works out,
we're gonna try it with salt.
[Music]
What is it?
It's lighter fluid
and it's cold out so...
Are you sure it's not water?
[Music]
Guys, it's under 60 degrees.
I am unhappy.
This makes me happy.
I'm a witch, I cannot burn.
[Music]
All right, that looks
like it should be big enough
to cover most of that steak.
So I'm just going to try
cutting a star shape out,
and we're going to use
that as a stencil
as we sandblasting.
We're going to see
if it really does anything
to the steak or not.
So again,
because this was
a DIY sandblaster,
we did file in that hole.
So we're just going
to add that bottle.
[Music]
So when your sandblasting
and your etching,
let's see glass,
it's usually only
at about 30 PSI.
I believe the wood was 90.
So what are we using
for the the steak?
[muffled voice]
Cool.
Let's start low,
and then try higher.
So we're going to start low,
and we're going
to work our way up.
[Music]
I got all the personal
protection equipment on.
Let's try sandblasting a steak.
[Music]
It is really stuck on there.
That--
That sand is quite well stuck
into the steak, I think.
I think, at this point,
you're not going
to get an indentation.
I think you're just going
to get a charred star where the
where the sand is.
It's possible.
Let's try it,
like let's crank the PSI up,
and try it like a hundred.
[Music]
What did you do?
Oh my gosh.
All right.
A hundred PSI.
That's what it will do
to your skin.
It turns out at 100 PSI
and 40 PSI do very different
things in a sandblaster.
That is pulverized.
Now, maybe at 30,
it would just bounce off your
skin and sting a little bit.
But don't do it at a hundred.
That was pretty nuts,
watching it just carve
into the steak,
and we want to do it again.
We're going to try and catch it
in a little bit of slow motion,
and see how much
that's really digging in there,
because that seemed insane.
Do you think we
can cut it in half?
I bet we could.
Let's try it.
[Music]
Yeah, there's steak
on the camera lens.
That's cool.
We've hit a steak with sand,
and now, we want to see
what happens if we use something
that won't destroy our teeth
and be completely inedible.
So we're going to try pouring
some salt into our sandblaster,
and see if that has
the same effect.
[Music]
I've never tried
saltblasting anything before,
so I don't know what
it's abrasive power is.
So real quick,
I'm just going to try hitting
a piece of glass with it,
and see if it etches
that the way the sand does.
[Music]
Nope.
Nothing.
So salt is not nearly
as hard as the sand we were
using as an abrassive before,
so it does not etch
the glass the same way
that the sand does.
I still think it's going
to get through the steak.
It's not even salty.
We saw what the salt
did to glass.
I don't think this is going
to do nearly as much damage
as it did with the sand,
but I do think it's going
to tenderize the meat,
maybe just a little.
[Music]
That seemed to tear
into it more,
even though it's
at the lower PSI.
Yeah.
How strange?
[Music]
There you go.
So at 40 PSI,
it really does just seem
to stick onto the surface.
It doesn't carve into it.
60, it started going
in a little bit,
and we saw what a hundred did
with sand, now,
I think we want to try
a hundred of salt
on the other side of this.
It's already chewed up
a little bit from the 60.
I'm gonna chew it up a lot.
[Music]
So...
Oh no.
Steaks are sometimes tenderized
by like little knives going in,
and cutting up some
of the fibers.
I think we may have found
a different way to go
about doing that.
This is...
This is a new way
to make ground beef.
Just about.
Oh boy, that's exciting.
That is just shredded.
Look at that texture.
Let's throw this on the grill.
I wonder if it's
gonna be any good.
Yeah, let's find out.
[Music]
All right.
So now we've ripped
up a few steaks,
some with salt,
some with sand.
None are looking really tasty.
So let's make some edible ones.
The one we shredded
with salt might still be good,
but we don't know yet.
It's still cooking.
We'll try it.
We're going to try using
a few different kinds of things.
We've got some different
kinds of seasoning.
We've got some garlic salt,
some steak dust that we,
I think will mix with some salt,
and we're going to try
a medium PSI, maybe
the 60 that was sort of tearing
into the steak a little bit,
but not shredding it.
I like it.
So the first mix
that we're going to try is
just simple garlic salt.
Should be pretty good.
[Music]
Oh, I can taste
the garlic in the air.
All right, so we have tenderized
the garlic salt steak.
Let's throw it on the grill.
This is the piece of steak
that we shredded with salt.
On the other side,
you can see it's
completely toe up.
This piece of steak
has nothing on it yet.
We're going to see what happens
if we salt blast it
after it's completed cooking.
Similarly to the other piece
of steak that we're going
to try sandblasting cooked.
All right.
I think we've got
some other flavors we can try.
Yeah, let's do it.
Now, this is like a fine powder.
So we are keeping
the salt in there,
just so we've got something
that's going to be
a little bit stronger.
Also, can we throw
this one on the grill?
That's the one we cut
in half with sand.
So yes, we just have to make
sure we don't eat it afterward.
Challenge accepted.
No, don't eat that.
Your teeth will be gone
and your happiness.
My dad's a dentist.
All right.
We're going to go
for about 80 PSI.
A hundred shreds it.
60 barely gets
into it a little bit.
40 just decorates the surface.
Let's try 80.
I think 80 is a little high.
To the grill?
One more for the grill.
Guys, there's nothing
better than eating Science.
And for those of you
who are saying we're just doing
this experiment as
an excuse to eat steak,
not only,
but like I mean partly.
Mostly.
While Nate finishes
cooking these,
I'm going to go ahead and see
if I can salt blast
a cooked steak,
and see if we can cut
that in half, too.
[Music]
That was with salt.
This is so salty.
It's good though.
All right.
So this is sand steaks.
We're not going
to eat these ones
because they're covered in sand.
This one, we're going
to now sandblast,
even though it's been cooked.
[Music]
All right, let's take a look
at what we've made here.
So this plate...
Oh, with an exacto knife on it.
Oh, there you go.
This plate is entirely
non-edible at this point.
Well, okay.
So that, was any of the salt,
there's a salt--
>> This is all sand.
Okay.
These two are
what we sandblasted
before we cook them.
That's right.
And we just cooked them to see
what would happen.
And then we sandblasted
this one afterwards.
After we cooked it.
Yes, and it did shred into it.
Although not quite as easily
as it shredded into this one.
And then these two,
the bigger pieces
here, we've got...
This is garlic salt.
Yours is the one--
>> Steak dust.
Steak dust.
So this one,
we cooked first,
and then we salt blasted,
and this one was actually salt
blasted before we cooked it.
Correct.
It's probably way too salty.
Yeah, we're not going
to eat that one.
I think we need
to taste everything.
See how it-- I am curious
about these ones,
because like we did use
quite a bit of salt
and garlic flavoring,
like being sprayed down
into them that may not be
a great way to make steak.
Let's see.
[Music]
Slightly overcooked.
That is...
That is very salty.
Oh boy.
Is that ever?
I'm going to try the one
that we hit with 100 PSI
and like chewed up.
Wait.
I'm trying this too.
We go down together.
Oh my gosh.
There is no flavor except salt.
And now you get to watch
10 minutes of us eating steak.
[Music]
I don't really recommend you use
sandblaster on your steak.
It's not a good way to get
a nice even distribution.
Just sprinkle some on.
Works way better.
Yeah.
Guys, that's all for today.
But there's always more
for you to see.
That box up at the top
will take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And if you haven't subscribed
to the channel yet,
hit this bomb to get
in the club,
and that way, you'll
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.